MUSIC AND MOVIES WERE MADE
FOR EACH OTHER.
DECADES BEFORE TALKIES,
MOVIES HAD MUSIC.
THEY NEEDED MUSIC, AND MUSIC
NEEDED THEM RIGHT BACK.
THESE ARE THE NOMINEES
FOR BEST SCORE.
"DA 5 BLOODS" BY
TERENCE BLANCHARD.
"MANK" BY TRENT REZNOR
AND ATTICUS ROSS.
"MINARI" BY
EMILE MOSSERI.
"NEWS OF THE WORLD" BY
JAMES NEWTON HOWARD.
"SOUL" BY TRENT REZNOR,
ATTICUS ROSS, AND JON BATISTE.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
TRENT REZNOR, ATTICUS ROSS,
AND JON BATISTE FOR "SOUL."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
HELLO. HELLO.
MAN, YOU KNOW WHAT’S
DEEP IS THAT GOD GAVE
US 12 NOTES. IT’S THE SAME 12
NOTES DUKE ELLINGTON HAD,
BACH HAD. IT’S THE SAME 12.
NINA SIMONE.
AND ALL THE NOMINEES,
I JUST WANT TO FIRST POINT OUT
THAT EVERY GIFT IS SPECIAL.
EVERY CONTRIBUTION WITH MUSIC
THAT COMES FROM THE DIVINE,
INTO THE INSTRUMENTS,
INTO THE FILM, INTO THE MINDS
AND HEARTS AND SOULS OF
EVERY PERSON WHO HEARS IT.
THE STORIES THAT HAPPEN
WHEN YOU LISTEN TO IT
AND WATCH IT, AND THE
STORIES YOU SHARE, THE MOMENTS
YOU CREATE, THE MEMORIES
YOU MAKE.
MAN, IT’S JUST SO INCREDIBLY
SPECIAL AND I JUST WANT TO FIRST
RECOGNIZE THE NOMINEES
AND SAY THAT I’M INCREDIBLY –
I’M SPEAKING FOR ALL OF US –
WE ARE INCREDIBLY HUMBLED
AND GRATEFUL TO THE ACADEMY
FOR THIS RECOGNITION, AND I’M
JUST THANKFUL TO GOD FOR
THOSE 12 NOTES. MAN, THAT’S SO DOPE.
THANK YOU TO MY PARENTS, SULEIKA
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND LOVE,
COMING HERE WITH ME, YOU FLEW
ON A PLANE FIRST TIME IN A YEAR.
MY PARENTS TOOK ME AROUND
CLUBS IN NEW ORLEANS
WHEN I WAS TEN YEARS OLD.
PUT ME IN PIANO LESSONS.
MISS SHIRLEY, WILLIAM. JUST SO MUCH,
SO MUCH HAS HAPPENED.
THIS MOMENT IS A CULMINATION
OF A SERIES OF MIRACLES.
AND I JUST CAN’T EVEN GO
INTO ALL OF THEM.
WE DON’T HAVE THAT MUCH TIME,
BUT IT'S JUST SO INCREDIBLY POWERFUL
TO BE STANDING HERE IN THE
LINEAGE THAT WE COME FROM
AND THE LINEAGE IN THIS FILM,
THE COLLABORATORS ON THIS FILM
ARE THE BEST THAT YOU COULD
HAVE EVER ASKED FOR
THE MOST GENEROUS, RIGOROUSLY
VISIONARY, COLLABORATIVE.
PETE DOCTER IS A – I LOVE THIS MAN –
PETE DOCTER, HE’S A GENIUS
AND A VISIONARY. DANA MURRAY,
KEMP POWERS, TOM MCDOUGALL AT DISNEY.
THANK YOU FOR WELCOMING US
TO THE FAMILY WITH OPEN ARMS.
SO MUCH OF A TRUE COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS. MY TEAM. THANK Y’ALL FOR
JUST DEALING WITH ME ’CAUSE MY,
I GET IDEAS ALL THE TIME,
CHANGING DIRECTION.
Y’ALL HOLDING ME DOWN.
MICHAEL, CHRIS, ADAM, ALL THE
PEOPLE. AND THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH FOR DOING WHAT YOU ALL
DO AND PUTTING IT ON THE LINE.
PUTTING YOURSELF OUT THERE. IT’S
HARD TO PUT YOURSELF OUT THERE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR PUTTING
YOURSELF OUT THERE.
I’M A FAN OF LIKE EVERYBODY HERE.
SO, MUCH LOVE, MUCH LIKE TO YOU.
I LOVE YOU EVEN IF
I DON’T KNOW YOU.
LATER ON.